Hi everyone, welcome to the price
rejector preview. My name is Michael
Valtos. I'm the founder and trader at
orderflows.com. First, a brief
disclaimer. This presentation is for
educational andformational purposes only
and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision. Futures trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor. An investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment. Risk capital is
money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle. Only risk capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading. Past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future
results. Okay. So what I'm going to talk
about today is the new indicator that we
had programmed. It's called the price
rejector. And what it means or why we
called it the price rejector is because
it's going to give you an indication
when price appears to be rejected in the
market. Now, you know, if you're a
regular order flows user, my usual
software, you know, the main way I I
look at orders flows being rejected is
with the ratios. You know, when you see,
you know, a blue number, it's sort of at
the end of a move like here and here.
That's a sign of rejection. However,
there's another sign of rejection. When
this one is more of a macro view, I say
macro view, but you know, more of a
longer term view
in the market. uh you know when you're
looking at this individual bar it's
based on this bar that you're getting
the ratio whereas a price rejector is
taking into account a few other things.
It's taken into account the volume in a
bar volume in the bottom of a bar you
know after a move that's happened. It
calculates you know that a move's
happened.
It also calculates you know the price
action of the bar that the bar you know
there has to be you know for a buy
signal it has to be indicating that
there's buying going on and for a sell
signal has to indicate that there's
selling going on and it has
to be you know like I said at
the you know after a move that's
happened you mean if you're looking for
a reversal you have to have a move to
reverse you can't reverse something you
know when you're sort of in the middle
of an area so you know the price
rejector takes into accounts a few
things. You know, it takes into account
that a move has already occurred. It
takes into account that volume has been
decreasing, takes into account
that opposite price action has been
happening. So, you know, if the market's
been selling off, what you want to see,
you want to see the selling decrease and
you want to see buying
increase. And the last
one is some form of market imbalance.
Now, you know, markets
move because it's looking for a fair
price to trade for people to trade. And
you know, a lot of people will call that
the noise in the market where the market
just trades back and forth. Well, that's
not really noise. I mean, what's
happening is trade is being facilitated.
The market's doing what it's supposed to
do. Once it moves away from a fair price
to an unfair price, that's where you're
going to get often times you're going to
get rejection. That's where the price
rejector comes in. So, you know, it's
looking at basically, you know, the four
factors that I just explained. So, you
know, I'll just sort of walk you through
a few charts. It was designed, you know,
all my indicators are designed to run on
an orderflows chart. I think that works
best. I think that you should not just
take trading signals blind. You have to
take everything in in context of the
market. I mean obviously with the
indicators like the delta scalper and
the orderflows trader you know looking
at it order flows chart will you know I
think
will make it better because then you
could analyze what's actually happening
in the markets. So I'm just going to run
through uh a few days of charts here.
This is the E- mini. This is a five
range chart. This is uh the 13th of May,
Friday the 13th. And here you go. Okay.
It's going to be the signal. Usually I I
don't like to have the the the zone
drawn out. You you can adjust that. If
you're looking for it to be a support or
resistance level, you might want to have
the zone. In this example, I I put the
zone in there. This the zone. You can
adjust the length on how many bars out
you want it to be. I have it set at
five, but I do like to have a hash, a
green hash for a buy and a red hash for
a cell. When you see the cell, you
you'll see a red hash up there. And so,
okay, here we go. This is uh 7:30 in the
morning. you have a a buy signal right
here and you know the market went up
right it reversed off this move down and
then you know we sort of hit our swing
high came back down and you're seeing
another area of price rejected and and
the market went back up here uh scroll
forward here's one it failed this is a
sell this was a you know you see the the
red hash there again you can adjust you
know if if you're using my software you
can you know if you don't adjust it it's
going to go right over it You can adjust
it, you know, if you want a little bit
higher, a little bit lower. I think if
you put zero in, it'll appear right on
top of of the top uh volume. But, you
know, I mean, it's or you can adjust the
colors. And, you know, right now I got
dark red on this this chart. If if I had
a lighter red, then I'd be able to see
through it. But, you know, this was an
area where, you know, it was giving you
a signal that, you know, possible price
rejection. It didn't happen. You know,
market just went sideways. often times,
you know, what you're going to have is,
you know, like I said, a market's going
to move from a fair fair price to an
unfair price and then back to a fair
price. Now, that doesn't mean that it's
just going to bounce back up and down.
You know, sometimes it's going to take a
market a while to find the fair price.
So, you have your first signal here that
maybe there's there's a there's price up
here, you know, some price rejection and
it's just rejecting the
market. But, it doesn't reject it. It
just goes sideways. Usually, if it's
just going sideways on you, that that's
a good sign that it may just sort of
continue. Again, you know, just because
market's looking for a fair price
doesn't mean it's going to hit a high
and come off. It can just keep going
until it finds that fair price. Right
now, it kind of paused here and, you
know, you didn't get the sell-off that
you're looking for if you're short. I
mean, obviously, if you're trading, you
should be using some form of tight
stops. You know, your tight stops would
just be right on the other side of of
this high. You know, it's not going to
be, you know, four or five
ticks past this high and this is a five
range chart. You know, you should have a
tight a tight stop. But I mean, here
you're getting moves of, you know, you
saw earlier this move here was, you
know, what 55 up to 59. You know, here
it was 50, you know, whatever 54 and a
half all the way up to, you know,
basically back up to 59 again. Okay. So,
you know, is it worth risking, you know,
a point, a point and a half, you know,
to get a few points, you know, three
points, four points profit? I I think
so.
Okay, hang on
here. So, you know, again, what you're
looking for, you know, is are these
areas here. Again, you don't have to
use, you know, these zones drawn out.
You know, I have them here, so it's a
little bit easier to see in this
video. Hang on, my computer's acting up.
It's because I got a lot of charts on my
screen running.
Okay. So, okay. Was there there was no
sell up here. Let's see. So, we came
back
down and again, you know, down here
again at around this 56 56 and a half
level, you're seeing some signs of price
rejecting. Now, you have a ratio as
well, which is, you know, an extra I'll
say extra bonus, but, you know, it's a
sign that you're seeing price rejection.
You know, ideally, that's why I like to
use it with the orderflow chart. It will
run on a normal bar chart. I'll go over
some bar chart examples with you a bit
later
on. And you know these any of these
trades have the ratios? I don't think
so. I mean ideally you know you you'd
want to get some sort of you know
confluence. Okay here there's no ratio.
There there's no ratio. Um this one you
did have a ratio you know which by
itself is indicating price
rejection. Okay. Okay. So, you know, the
market did pop up, you know, 57 and a
quarter or what to 60 before coming back
off. You know, again, it's not a trade
that's going to go to infinity. You
know, this is a five range chart. I
mean, you know, that's the thing that
that bothers me sometimes with with
traders, especially newer traders, is
they think every trade has got to go to
in go to infinity. It's got to last in
infinite amount of of time. You know,
when you're trading, market goes up,
goes down, things change in the market.
So, you know, if if you're again, if
you're using an orderflows chart, you
know, what's the sign that that oops
that that things have changed? You know,
if you're seeing a selling imbalance in
here, so if you're long in here, all of
a sudden, you see a selling imbalance.
Obviously, things have changed in the
market. Sellers have have taken over.
So, you know, if you were long and you
didn't take a profit, you know, seeing
this is is a sure sign to get get out of
the market, you know. But again, you
know, don't don't think every trade that
you have is got to be a 10point winner.
It's not like that. I mean, you know,
trading you have the goal is to last a
long time. And it means, you know,
taking either, you know, taking trades
that are going to keep you in the market
for how many months, you know, and then
just keep building up the position or
taking, you know, a series of of smaller
trades for smaller profits and smaller
losses.
Okay. So, here's one. It didn't, you
know, so this buy here, yeah, it went
up. It went up a couple points. You
could have got something out of it. This
one started to, then turned around and
and came off. It stopped you out. You
know, I said not every trade is going to
be a a slam dunk winner. And sometimes
the market hasn't found its level that
it wants to reverse. You know, when
you're I'm not trying to pick the low,
but I'm trying to pick an area where a
low can occur. You know, where there's
price rejection. Usually, you know, if
you're looking to buy, you want to buy
in an area where the prices below that
area are being rejected, you know. So, I
think this trade, you know, would give
you a lowrisk trade. Your stop is just
going to be down, you know, below here,
below this level. You know, I like where
this bar is. You know, that would be my
stop. So, you know, if I'm getting long
in here, you know, basically I'm risking
one, two, three, four, five, six ticks,
a point and a half. I could live with
that. You know, we finally find our low
here and you know, you're getting along
around the 54 54 and a quarter level and
you trade right up to the next level at,
you know, is that 58 58 and a half.
Well, I don't think you would have sold
58 and 1 halfs. I think, you know,
50, you know, 58. Hey, I mean, that's,
you know, four points right there. You
risk, you know, here you risk a point
and a half. You lost and then boom, you
get you make it right back. Okay, this
one, you know, it kind of struggled.
Honestly, it struggled. It's started to
come off. I mean, it did come off a
little bit, sort of came back up. You
know, it hadn't found its level. And
then the market sold off finally. Then
you come right down to another level
here. Okay, this one went up sort of
traded around. Okay, then it
failed. You know, again with I when I
use these these zones again, I like
to, you know, the reason why I have
zones, you know, for me, you know, when
I'm looking at something as support and
resistance, it's support and resistance
in the near term. It's not supporting
resistance for the entire day of
trading. That's why I have five five
levels. So, if the trade's not really,
you know, if I'm in the trade in five
levels out and it's hardly paying off,
I'm not looking to for the market
necessarily to come out and and stop me
out. You know, in in this case, we got
up to the sixth level before it turned
around. But it could have very easily
just gone keep going up. You know, in
this case, we got to this level. you
know, it's in the fourth level, fifth
level, sixth level. It's still in there.
Still hanging around un, you know, a
little bit, you know, in profit a little
bit before finally selling
off. Okay, you know, here we're going
higher, higher. Didn't really reach our
level. Didn't get a price rejecting, you
know, right on the high, but in this
case, you know, you got some decent
stopping volume up there. You could sort
of read that in the order flow yourself,
I think.
Then we get to this level here. This is
11. You know, I just chose this day. Um,
you I didn't cherrypick a a perfect day.
There's going to be days where there's a
lot more winners than losers. There's
going to be some days where you have
probably more losers than winners. I'll
be honest with you. This is not a 100,
you know, trading is not a 100% thing.
It's, you know,
there's so many factors that you can't
factor into the market. I mean, you
don't know that as soon as you you click
buy that there's somebody at at Deutsche
Bank that's got a big sell order that
they got to get filled. You know, you
could buy your five lots thinking, "Hey,
I got the best trading setup in the
world." Then, you know, 30 seconds
later, the guy at Deutsch Bank says,
"Okay, hey, I got to sell 5,000 S&Ps."
Boom. And market sells off two points.
What do you do? You know, that that's
life. That that happens. You don't know
when it's going to happen.
But it does does more than than people
care to uh care to admit. Okay, so
here's one here's a case where you know
we're sort of struggling. You get a
sell, you get some sign of of price
rejection, you know, we come right up to
that level again and now you get a sign
of some stopping
volume. And you know, I just said, you
know, when you get into the fifth bar,
which is this bar, you know, I'm usually
looking to get out. But you know once we
get in sort of in the middle and then I
get another sign yeah I'll probably be
looking to hold it a bit more and then
we just you know we sold off from you
know what is that 57 57 and a half
rather you know down to down to three
and a half you know we did get another
signal down
here this one you know we didn't quite
find our level down here we sort of
found our level yeah sort of went
sideways before you know the selling
came back
in, you know, another level that that
failed. You know, I wish every single
level was was a big winner, but you
know, sometimes now the market doesn't
necessarily find
its find its its low that it's going to
reject. As I said, you know, the
market's in a in a constant state of of
flux. And usually by three o'clock I'm
not looking to trade, you know, cash
close and just not interested at that
point. Okay, just real quick also what I
want to show is on a Forex chart. I said
I'm not a Forex trader, but you know a
lot of people ask can you know these
indicators work with with Forex? Yeah, I
I think they can because as long as your
data is good. This is the FXCM feed from
Kinetic, which to the best of my
knowledge is the the FXCM feed that you
trade off of. Now, you know, obviously
FX is is something that trades around
the
market and you know, there's going to be
times where there's more liquidity than
than not. Obviously, I think the times
when there's most liquidity is best for
trading, but you know, the FX
market is a 24-hour market.
So, you know, again, I I hate I'm not a
spot player. I I like to trade during
the the normal trading day. And problem
with FX for me at least, I mean, for my
way, I think, is I'm not someone that's
going to come sit down in front of a
screen for 30 minutes and start trading.
You know, if I'm trading, I'm keyed into
the market and seeing what's happening,
you know, during that time. It's not I
I, you know, look at it on on my phone,
see where the market is. Okay. Yeah. No,
you know, and trade like that. You know,
for me, I like to set aside, you know,
the same time of day for the most part
to to trade and analyze the market. You
know, you have to part of trading is
having the right psychological
uh surroundings, you know, in your
office at, you know, certain times of
the day. That's what you want to do. You
know, FX guys, it's not something where
you can just turn it on and turn it off
and start taking and start taking
signals. Now, so that said, okay, I'll
just I'll just go through a few days.
Cuz honestly, I don't know how this this
panned out. I just happen to have the
chart
running, you know, with the indicator
on. I'm kind of curious myself. So, you
know, here was one a sell signal. The
thing with with FX is sometimes it
doesn't necessarily turn around on the
dime the way futures have the tendency
to partly because there's a bit of
arbitrage going on between the the
futures and the cash market. I don't
think people are arbing the the CME euro
against the FXCM euro, but still uh you
know
oftentimes I've always noticed that I've
always felt that you get a little bit of
a pop, you know, say you get a sell
signal, sometimes you get a bit of a pop
up through it before the market goes in
a direction that that you're
anticipating. And part of it, I think,
is just because of the the ARB that's
going on in the cash market. I don't
know where FXCM gets their feed from,
which bank or you know, so series of
banks. I'm sure they they deal with one
bank, but or maybe they're just so big
that they, you know, they got this their
own flow. I I don't know. I don't I
don't trade forex, and I don't claim to
be a big uh Forex guy. So, here we go.
Okay, so there's a sell signal. Yeah, I
mean, most of my charts I I do have a
lot of the data uh all day long. So, but
there are gaps in my data sometimes as
when I have to turn off my computer. So,
that said, okay, here's a cell. Yeah, it
did. Yeah. Yeah, we got you got some
pips. You know, I hate dealing with
these FX guys cuz they always Oh, I'm
getting my pips on. Getting my pips
on, you know, just make money. Here's a
sell. This is around I don't know what
that is. 38. Yeah, it didn't really sell
down. Came down to around the 30 level.
Yeah, here is where I'm missing some
data. Uh, okay. Again, here's a buy. You
know, that's what I talk about where it
Oh, sorry. Here's one I missed. You
know, this one didn't work out. This
one, you got the little break before it
went up. This one didn't work out. You
know, I don't know if I should be
showing this. Okay, here's a nice one.
There's a nice
sell. Unfortunately, this is at 8:30
p.m. Chicago
time, you know, but it's a nice one. You
know, this is a fiveminute
chart. 20 25
ticks cells, a smaller one here. Got a
gap here in data.
Okay, here's a buy. Yeah, it kind of
worked out a little bit. Mostly
sideways. Not claiming any big victory
there. Uh, let's see. Here's a here's a
little buy again. Kind
of kind of went quiet sometimes, you
know, after 1:00, you know, especially
on day was that the 5th? That's
Thursday. It's Thursday ahead of
non-farm
payrolls. Uh, well, here's a cell. Well,
that's, you know, 6:00 at night
basically. But yeah, I'm missing some
data in there, so I don't know what
happened. This is the non-farm payrolls.
That's why you see it trade up to 80 and
down to
05. Here's one. You know, I'm always I
don't like to take signals on the first
bar of the day. Uh because sometimes it
doesn't, especially, you know, on this
indicator where it reads back
uh previous data. So, if I'm missing
data, so say I just start it and you're
missing some data, it's going to give
you a a wonky signal the first time.
This is what this is uh the 9th. This is
ready the next week, the Monday. And so
here's an signal signal to get short.
You know, you get short around the 05.
You know, it trades down to 85. That's
20 or so ticks there. Even there turned
around again. You know, it's not
something this is a five minute chart.
How long you going to hold a a trade on
a fiveminute chart
for? You know, this is what time is
that? 7:40, you know, by 9:00. Again,
you're getting short on a 5minute chart
at at 7:40. You're not going to be
holding it until 1:00. I mean, if you
did, yeah, that'd be great, but you
would have taken some heat up here. You
know, really on a 5minute chart, you got
to ask yourself how long you going to
hold it for. You know, if you're going
to be holding a trade from 7:30 in the
morning until 1 2 in the afternoon, you
probably shouldn't be trading a
fiveminute
chart. So, here's another one. This is
130. a little bit, you know. Yeah, it's
a little sell. You know, it's nothing
spectacular. Okay, this this is on the
10th. So, here's a here's a nice buy.
You know, it wasn't no breach there, but
you know, went from 70 all the way up
here into the
90s. I got a sell signal, but you know,
this one I have my data ends here at
10:00.
get a little bit of a sell off before it
turns around the 11th. You know, some,
you know, this one, yeah, it didn't
really work out that great. It got
worked out a little bit, but still just
sort of went sideways on
you. Uh, here's two that failed. Well,
this, well, actually, I don't say
failed. Did get a little bit of a pop,
then
fail. Now, usually when you're trading,
you get long, you get that initial pop,
and then it doesn't continue. This is
usually not a good sign, especially once
you see the red candles coming in that
you know, hey, you know, don't expect it
to come right back down to your low a
third time and then turn around. We
eventually found our low here, uh,
7:05. You know, you getting long
somewhere around the 85. You know, we
trade back up to 10. And here's one.
Didn't really work out. It sort of
probed higher and then came
off.
Here's a little one, you know, worked
out again from this 75 area up to the
almost to the 90 area. Here's one just
kind of went sideways. It's already
1:00. That's what the 12th, Friday the
13th. Okay, this is evening session.
Don't have the full
data here. This is the European morning
uh about 2:45 Chicago time. Well, this
one here, we came out, took out the low,
you know, didn't hold. Again, it's my
look back is 1, two, three, four, five,
six, seven. I think I forgot what it
was. Seven. I think I got nine. Second,
I don't know if I would even would have
taken the signal here because, you know,
my look back period is nine. Definitely
the first bar I won't
take. But if my look back period is
nine, I I might be willing to take it.
Probably not uh for this example. And
I'll say
no, even though it did uh did turn
around. You know, here was a nice buy.
Yeah, it popped up initially, then just
went sideways, started coming
down. This was a sell. Got the pop up
through it initially. No, didn't really
work. Uh, okay. Where am I here? 16th
again. That's the That's the sell on
the, you know, the second bar. This one,
it was a buy. It's kind of choppy. The
16th was
uh it's a
Monday. Uh, yeah, it popped up, but then
just, you know, really didn't, you know.
Yeah. Okay. You got a pop, but then it
just kind of went
sideways. Okay. Where am I? Anything
else here? No, not much. And here's a
buy that just sort of went sideways
before selling
off. You know, again, you're getting
along here at at 6:15. And if you're
holding it and the market hasn't paid
off by by 7:15, you know, you shouldn't
be holding it. And I said, if the trade
is not paying
off, you know, an hour after you're into
the trade, you shouldn't still be in the
trade. You know, get out. Get out with
with a small profit or something. Don't
don't wait for it. Don't think it's I
said don't wait for infinity. You know
the trade's not going to run to
infinity. At some point you should be
looking to get out. And you know this is
one of those cases where people say well
yeah look it finally you know some of
these vendors will say hey look it trade
all the way up to 45 you know you're
long for 20. Well yeah it also went down
but again you know if the trade's not
going in your favor you know after an
hour on a 5minute chart you really
shouldn't be holding a trade. I mean
that's I mean that's that's simple. you
should getting paid on a trade and you
should be getting paid, you know,
relatively quickly. Okay, now this is a
crude chart. This is a Reno
chart to see how it how it worked.
Again, you know, I'm just, you know, I
started the the analysis starting May
5th. So, you see 52. It's not February
5th. It's this is the on my setup. I
have it set to the European standard.
So, you see the the day then the month.
And people say, "Why are you looking at
a a June contract on in February?" I'm
not. The way my computer's set up is the
dates are European schedules. So you see
the 2nd of February. Okay.
So, and this is a Monday. That's why I'm
starting here. First Monday, first day,
first training day of May. Okay. This
one, you know, and this chart, I
believe,
is I think I have it set
as I want to call my uh Mike's index
hours, which is basically Yeah,
basically 7 in the morning till until I
think uh 4:00 Chicago. 7 in the morning
Chicago time till 400 p.m. Basically the
the
main index hours in the US. Okay, so
here's a buy. Yeah, it didn't really
work out. Yeah, it did take some heat.
Honestly, this is a little bit too much
heat for me before it turned around. And
then down here, you see a little bit of
a cell. Kind of went sideways. Nothing
spectacular.
Oops. Okay. So, it's going sideways
here. This one failed. Okay. Boom. Here
you get a
nice a nice sell um you know around the
45 40 level. Boom. What we trade? We
trade all the way down to 459. 50 points
50 ticks in in the crude actually even
went down lower. It's from 4540 went
down here to 45 you know 60 65 before
you got a buy signal then went back up
from 65 back up to you know 45 even. So
you know you could risk a little bit
here. You have you know you're getting
short here. You have a stop
here. You know, if you're getting short
when this bar closes, you know, you're
getting short
4526, you have stop around, you know,
33, 34. You know, 33 is fine. 34, we'll
call it 30. Get short at at 20, you
know, 26ish area up to, you know, 34,
that's that's 8 ticks. Okay, that's
fine. That's eight ticks risk. Some
people say that's too much. Well, are
you willing to
risk
this? Close this. you know, are you
willing to risk like a bar like this?
You know, eight ticks to get something
like this or even just get this I'd much
rather risk eight ticks to get, you
know, get this and get
this. Okay. And then, you know, later,
you know, 1:00. I don't really like to
trade look at crude that much after
after
one cuz most of the big traders are
already finished trading for the day by
1:00. You do have the markers later, but
still, you know, Europe is closed. Asia
is obviously in the middle of the night
already. Better off trading it during
the main the main session. So, that was
what day was that? That was the first,
sorry, the second first trading day of
the month. Here you get a buy signal.
Didn't really work out. You know, it did
pop up a little bit before stopping you
out. Again, if you're trailing your
stop, you can figure out where to put
it. you know, maybe you want to tighten
it a little bit after it starts going in
your favor. So, instead of risking the
full eight ticks, you know, once it
starts popping up in your favor, you
move your stop up to to to minus
4. It depends, you know, on your trading
style. You may want to risk the full
amount, okay? Or or not. You know, it
really there's different ways to trade.
You know, there's no one right way to
trade. Here was a sell. This one failed.
Stopped you out. You lose you know, if
you're you know, it stopped you out
pretty quick. you're losing your full
eight
ticks. And now here's a sell again.
4375. That's a 50 tick winner basically.
Or not 50 ticks. It's, you know, 40
ticks before it starts turning around
here. There wasn't any buy signal here.
Would have been nice if you get a buy
signal. You know, once a steep sell-off
occurs and then you start going back up,
you know that that's where you're
looking to get out. Again, it's after
one here. I'm not necessarily looking to
take any trades. This one's too
early. You I talked about taking
signals, right? you know, right around
right around the open. Let it settle.
Here's one. Yeah, it started to work
out. Then turn around, stop you out.
Okay, I can take that loss or I could
take, you know, I'm trailing my stop.
Maybe not as bad
as as you
would have it. Okay, then here you get
another nice signal. Yeah, you're
getting
short
4415ish,
44 10, what have you. It trades all the
way down to 80. Got a buy signal here.
Okay, maybe you can take some off. Okay,
and then, you know, it sort of goes
lower. You know, this one doesn't work
out. This one doesn't work
out. Here's a nice buy signal. Getting
along here again around the
4430. If you know, you're trailing your
stop, it probably would have stopped you
out at break even or small profit. If
not, you know, you're you're getting
along from
4430 where up, you know, I don't want
again, I'm not looking to hold it all
the way to the close,
but you know, going up until 1:00 here.
Yeah, I don't like to trade in say after
one, but hey, if if the trade is in my
favor, I'm going to try and ride it out
as long as I
can. Okay, so what day the next day is
the 5th of May. See, scroll forward a
bit. Okay, so you get a sell signal
here. Let's make this chart a little bit
bigger. All right. So, this is a nice
sell signal around 40. What price is
that?
4565ish. You know, it trades down into
the 30s. It's a good 30 points. You
know, here you get a buy signal. Kind of
goes sideways on
you. You know, maybe you get a little
bit out of it. Maybe you get a scratch,
maybe you get a small loss, you know,
but you just had a nice big winner here.
You get a sell. It did tick up through
you before coming off. You get a a sell,
sorry, a buy signal here that
fails. Clearly fails. Not saying you
would any other way you're going to
trade it. Like I said, you know,
sometimes the market doesn't necessarily
find its bottom when you're looking to
buy. You know, here, you know, you had a
bottom. This sort of corresponds to over
here. We tried to hold it twice. It
didn't. It just didn't, you know. I
mean, that's that's how the market is,
you know. Not everything holds. You get
one here that doesn't really
hold.
Okay. Okay. Here you get one. You kind
of reach it a bit. You know, it does
turn around before selling off. Again,
not every single, you know, sometimes,
you know, when you're trying to buy a
low, it's it's tricky. Here's one sell.
It did sell off a little bit before
turning around again. You sort of came
back up in here a little bit
later, but again, you know, this is
after 1. I'm not necessarily looking to
be taking trades after 1, especially,
you know, after 1 p.m. on a on on a
Thursday going into a Friday nonpart
payroll number. You could make make a
case that did sell off there, but I'm
not going to make that case. You know,
usually after 1:00, I'm not necessarily
looking to be trading crude.
Okay, so let's go into Friday again. You
know, this is the 6th of May. It's the
non-farm payroll day. So, you know, the
market's going to be a bit choppy. I
always find that the non-farm payroll
days a day I'm not necessarily looking
to trade. Here's a sell signal. Didn't
work out. It got stopped out pretty
quick.
Then you get a buy signal, you know, 8
after
8:30 and getting along somewhere, you
know, between
4392,
4395. You know, trades immediately, you
know, this one pops right up pretty
quick in a few minutes. Next thing you
know, it's trading 44 uh 4420 even keeps
going up up to 4430,
4440 before you get a sell signal. So,
you know, that's a move from, you know,
basically 95 up to 35. That's nice 40
points.
you get a sell signal here that that
stops you out. Okay. Are you willing to
take a little bit of risk here, you
know, here to get a move like this? I
know. I think you should be. I could be
wrong. You know, everyone wants to have
every single s signal be a big winner,
but you know, sometimes it, you know,
not every signal is going to be a big
winner. You know, here's a nice little
trade. You know, 4555 gets up towards
the 65 level before it just sort of
stalls out. You could just see even the
bars. Okay, compare this, right? You got
up, up, then down, up, down. It's a sign
that the market's struggling. You know,
here you got the big up move, but you
get green green green green up
up. You know, once you start going up up
and then you just go sideways, it's it's
usually a sign that, hey, this trade is
not necessarily really working out for
you. you might want to consider taking
some money, you know, taking taking
something off the table before rather
than letting it come all the way down to
stop to stop you out. I mean, that
that's that's me, but I'm not saying
that, you know, everybody can do
that. Okay, so this is next week. This
is Monday the 9th. So, here's a buy
signal talking about what is that 65.
you know, trades up to almost 80 before
turning around and coming down. Here's
again, here's another little buy signal.
It it worked and then it sort of ran up
here just just like here. You green,
green, green, and then red, red, red.
Are you going to let let the fourth,
fifth red bar come in, you know, get
green, green, green, then red, red, red?
Are you going to just let it come in and
and take you out? No. You should be
looking at to manage the trade, you
know, manage the trade. take get
something out of it whether you know
it's a small winner or small loss or a
break even don't have to let it come out
to stop you out that's people always do
they you know they don't manage their
risk they just think that you know hey
every trade's got to go to my profit
target or it's going to stop me out no
you know being a trader is maneuvering
in and out of the market the market's
going to give you opportunities to to
see what's going on and to get out you
know here's here's a trade you know gone
up from 10 to to 30 you know you could
have easily got 10 ticks out of it
easily. You know, you could have
probably gotten more out of it. Then you
get a sell signal here. Yeah. Okay. It
again, you know, knowing how to manage a
trade, you're going to let one tick stop
you out or you going to have it your
stop a little bit
further. You know, if you're trading
with a really tight stop, yeah. Okay.
Would have stopped you out. You know,
usually me, I like to give it two two
ticks, not just one tick on the high of
this this recent high. You know,
sometimes you will retest it and get
through it by a tick. I prefer, you
know, two to three ticks past here. But
I mean, that's up to
you. You know, if you're trading with an
ultra tight stop and you're using it one
tick past the high, you would have
missed this whole
move. Okay? So, you know, even if you
did get stopped out here, you get
another buy signal down here around the
4,400 level. And, you know, at least up
to 20 25. Honestly, I don't know how
this move turned out. Okay, we did get
up to 30 before starting to sell off.
You got two green, sorry, two red after
this series of of green. You might want
to, you know, see how it's going to pan
out before you necessarily get out at
20. You know, even if you did hold it
and got up here before it starts coming
off again, you know, second time you
start printing some red bars in
succession, I'd be looking to get
out. Okay, then you get another buy down
here. Again, same thing. Green, green,
green, then you got red, red, red. you
know where you going to get out. You
should be getting out somewhere in when
it's in in here rather than somewhere
down here. You know, don't let a winner
turn into a
loser. Okay, that's whatever. That's
right before the close. I wouldn't taken
it. I'll just go through Well, I'll just
get through this week with this crude
chart. I don't want this video being too
long. It's already over 30 minutes.
Okay. So, you come up here, you know,
this is what 8:00. You get a sell signal
here. You get to short somewhere around
the 85 level, 83,
85. You know, it's a quick 20
ticks, you know, before you get another
signal and get and sort of get stopped
out. Okay? Don't catch that whole move.
I mean, you love to catch the moves just
like this. Everybody wants a signal
that's going to tell them to buy here
and sell up here. Sometimes it's hard to
see. Okay, so let's see the next. Okay,
so you know there was well this my day
my data ended early that day. Um I
turned off my computer. I had some
something to do. So I actually turned
off my computer. That's why I got no
data. This is the 11th already,
Wednesday. That's the the inventory
number came out. No signals
yet. Okay. Got a little signal here,
sell signal here that didn't work out.
Okay, let's see. Okay, so this sell it
didn't work
out. Started to but then turned around
on
you again. You should know how to manage
your trades. It's it's something, you
know, when you know it starts to work
out, but then you get, you know, you can
see the candles being green against you.
That that's a sign that you try and get
out if you can, uh, you know, with a at
break even or a smaller
loss. Here's a sell. you know, you get
alternating candles. That's again,
that's not a good sign. And you're just
sort of hanging around your entry. Not a
good sign. You know, you don't need it
to pivot around here for one, two,
three, four, five bars before you know
the trade's not going anywhere. Yeah. If
you're getting short here and then you
just trade back up, trade back down,
trade back up, trade back down. Yeah, it
I don't know. It it I don't think you
need to be a PhD in trading to know that
the market's going
sideways, you know? I don't need it to
come up to here to stop me out. I'd
rather, you know, after one, two, three,
four bars going nowhere, basically
hanging around my entry price. That's a
good enough sign for me to try and get
out at a scratch or even, you know, a
couple thick loss rather than taking the
full
loss. Okay. So, you know, that day
ended, you know, wasn't that great a
day. You had, you know, one two trades,
I think, two or three trades and, you
know, they didn't really work out. Not
every day is going to give you a 50 50
tick winner. This is uh the 12th, which
is Thursday here. We're coming
into see if there's any signals again.
You know, I'm just I'm just choosing
these days. I mean, this is the first
two weeks of of May. Okay, here's a
here's a trade. Let's start it out.
Start it out. Then you see it turning on
you again. You want to wait till it
comes up here to stop you out or you
short here. It starts going in your
favor. you. Do you need it to turn
literally all the way against you before
you get out or are you going to be
managing your trade and getting out, you
know, around break even or, you know, a
smaller loss than than the full loss? I
mean, if you just using, you know, if
you're trading multiple lots and you
taken, you know, the first 10 ticks,
yeah, you got at least 10 ticks out of
that
trade, you know, similar thing here.
Down, down, turns around on you. Do you
need it
to come all the way back up there to to
stop you
out? Then here's one. You know, it's
1:00. You know, even though it did work
out, it said it's not a trade that I'm
it's not a time that I'm looking to
trade the market. So, that day wasn't
that great a
day. Okay, this is Friday the 13th.
Let's see if there's any signals here.
Okay, here's a sell. Didn't work out. I
think it would have stopped, you know, I
think it did stop me out. Got back up
there, you know, getting short around
this 18 level and trading around 24. To
me, that's that's clear enough through
there to to stop me
out. Okay. Then again, you sort of get
this side by side action. You know,
you're getting along here.
And I don't say you could you could
scalp this and get three or four ticks
out of it. I just be happy to take a
take a break even trade
there. But you know what? If you know to
watch it, you see if we're going to
come, you know, get through this level,
you know, there's probably going to be a
chance we're going to go lower instead.
You Well, I didn't even notice the time
on this one, but it was uh it was
already after one anyway. So, but you
know, when you're just looking at
it, I mean, really just staring at this
back and
forth, you know, regardless, you know,
had I taken this trade, you know, get
back and forth, back and forth
after, you know, like that that you're
looking at that, you try and get out.
You don't necessarily want to hold it,
you know, much more than than you really
need
to. So, what is Okay. Well, anyway, this
is the following week
here. Yeah. Yeah, this one I'm kind of
hesitant just because it's it's so close
so close to the open. I mean, this is
Monday. You know, this chart starts at
7:00 and we did open higher. You did get
a little bit of a selloff, but still,
you know, it's I'm not, you know, going
to say, hey, take that trade or by any
means. Uh, if anything, I'm just uh a
little bit hesitant right around when
when my chart starts. You know,
honestly, I'm a bit curious to see how
this this day turns out here. You know,
again, it's one o'clock. I mean, it's up
to you if you want to take trades after
one. I mean, it's Monday, so it's
probably a little bit more
interest. Yeah, this was a nice trade,
but you know, again, I'm not going to
sit here and say, "Yeah, this look at
this nice winner after I just said, you
know, I'm not looking to trade after
after 1 p.m. I know some people like to
trade until, you know, 2 p.m., which is
the old floor close, 2:10, I believe.
Me, no.
So, I'll just wrap this up here. So,
again, yeah, thanks for watching this
video. This was just sort of a preview
of of the new software that we're going
to be releasing soon. It's called the
price rejector.
If you're interested in it, just shoot
me an email. Um, you know, we're
probably going to release it any time
now. We're just working out some kinks.
If you know you want to learn more
about, you know, the order flows
software or the price rejector or the
delta scalper, you know, send me an
email. Um, you know, my email is
mike@orderflows.com or just visit the
website
www.orderflows.com. There's a form on
there you can fill out and and send me a
message. So, you as you can see, you
know, these charts they I showed you how
it works with a orderflow chart. I think
it works best with an order flows chart,
but you know, it can be used with a
normal bar chart. It can be used
with, you know, wrinkle charts. You can
look at it, you know, different time
frames. However you want, however you
trade it, you
can basically use it with any any type
of chart, any I'll say any time range.
Honestly, you know, if you're gonna say,
well, I tried it on a on a 15-second
chart and didn't work. Okay? I mean,
very few people trade on 15-second
charts. And you got to be realistic. You
know, you I'm willing to work with you
to make it work for you. You know,
sometimes people buy stuff and, oh, this
is the worst indicator. I've been
trading for 20 years. This is the worst
indicator ever. Well, if you've been
trading for 20 years, honestly, I don't
think you really need to be buying
indicators nowadays. You should have a
have a way of trading. I mean, I could
understand, you know, trying to add
something into your trading, but, you
know, if you've been trading for 20
years and you can't get something to to
sort of fit in, then, you know, maybe
your trading is so sophisticated that
you don't need
indicators. But, you know, if you're
going to say that, you know, at least
share some information like what sort of
time frame you're using it on or, you
know, what market you're looking at to
say, I tried it on every market out
there and every time frame. I trade
multiple time fra Well, come on. you
know, I could I I know this works. I
trade with it. I know other a few other
testers that have been using it are also
trading with it. So, dismiss it as
saying, you know, this this is crap. I
think is a bit harsh, especially if
you're not going to back it up with, you
know, any any examples. I mean,
I'm you I'm not out there to to scam
people out of money, although, you know,
some people feel that way when, you
know, something doesn't work to their
satisfaction. But, you know, people they
they expect that every indicator is
going to turn
their computer into a cash machine, you
know, that they can just turn it on and
print money. It's not like that. You
know, trading takes work. It takes
effort. It takes thinking. And, you
know, sometimes people don't don't want
to do any of the above.
But, you know, if you're willing to you
want to learn and you know, willing
to sort of I'll say take a leap of
faith, but you know, trust me and, you
know, trust that what I've got is
something that can make you money. Then,
you know, hey, by all means, let me
know. You know, I'm willing to to work
with you to get you up to speed. You
know, I even test I don't say I test
things for people, but people say, "Hey,
what what you know, I look at this
market, you know, what's a good time
frame to look at?" you know, tell me and
I know that everybody trades different
things and different time frames,
different markets, different time
frames,
and I also do.
So, if say you're trading on on a
10-minute chart and it's not really
working properly as as good as you would
like it, you know, let me know. I could
look into, you know, either I could
suggest, hey, maybe go down to a five
minute chart or or 10 range chart or
something, you know, different, you
know.
I can suggest you know I have my own
experience and I have our other users
experience as well you know so it's not
just tapping into my experience you're
also tapping into sort of a network of
other users as well you know people
share what works with me and you know
they say I ask them it's okay I share
this with other people and sometimes
they say no okay and I respect that and
sometimes they say yeah sure you know
because you know after all if
if with the markets what what works for
some people, you know, if they can get a
few more people to to follow and, you
know, everyone buys at the same level,
then it's then it's great. They'll make
more money
trading. So anyway, again, you know,
just visit our website
ww.orderflows.com and send me an email.
I'm not sure, you know, we'll probably
be releasing this software pretty soon.
And you said if it's something you're
interested, think it could work into
your trading, uh, by all means, let me
know and, you know, I'll get you set up.
So, thank you.